Donald trump's unexpected presidential.
When the rejection of the peace
agreement between the Colombian
government and the FARC,
the surprise Brexit victory folks 2016
what was the uh,
in which forecasts fails?
And it was precisely then there's an
ever present and very important
question.
Rose.
Once again,
all surveys useful ver anything and to
what extent can we trust these surveys?
Okay.
In a world where information is readily
available,
everywhere and changes are happening at
a dizzying pace,
pulse have become a political and
commercial weapon,
whether it's to gain votes or to sell
products.
Getting to new voters or customer's
tastes,
preferences and concerns is usually
highly recommended.
I believe me.
Wow.
Check this out.
John F.
Kennedy was the first White House
candidate who used and relied on poles
to prepare his campaign strategy.
Kennedy's team systematically used
surveys to discovering and analyze
voters opinions and concerns in such a
way that they'd be able to adapt to the
future president's political discourse
do these very issues.
Very example,
one of the surveys with which the
Kennedy team works revealed that only
30% of families could send their
children to university.
But that 80% of families still dreamed
of being able to do that someday.
Sorry,
can you guess what Kennedy did off the
last?
Well,
yes.
He insisted in his features a gain in
the game that education was a priority
for him and that he would improve
trading opportunities for every family's
children while the public,
they responded to this message,
well,
if we're going to absorb the new
technology,
we're going to have the have the path
train people in the world and they're
going to come out of this state and the
other 49 states
that was an old,
as you probably know,
John F.
Kennedy was Catholic and this wasn't
very well received and the Protestant
regions,
which is why many Protestant voters
weren't willing to vote for him.
Well,
the Kennedy team decided to use the
polls to decide which states the
candidate would visit during the
presidential campaign.
That way they left out new less than 30
states,
many of them precisely because of the
voters reluctance to vote for a Catholic
Candida's.
Thus the Kennedy campaigns in was able
to concentrate all of its efforts on the
states where they had a shot.
As you definitely know,
Kennedy became president.
As you can see,
polls I powerful weapon for drawing
political and business strategies.
That's why since Kennedy,
the vast majority of politicians have
had a great fondness for surveys and
demographic studies because well,
knowledge is power and not only that,
the polls have also acquired another
ability,
the ability to influence the decision
making process.
That is polls can actually gain votes or
clients by themselves,
whether by useful voting,
compromising,
coattail effect of voting.
It doesn't really matter.
Usually when a survey says that
something is in high demand,
it's natural demand tends to grow even
though it may never reach the savvis
levels.
It's exactly due to this effect.
There's Paula stations and many
companies are so addicted to
continuously making surveys of all
kinds.
However,
surveys on not always conducted as they
should be,
and that has led to some occasional very
huge mistakes.
I've just received a call from Secretary
Clinton.
The big mistakes
the years political polls have left
behind a huge trail of flaws and
mistakes of truly galactic proportions.
Perhaps one of the best known happens in
1936 you think presidential elections
were being held in the United States
that year and the magazine Literary
Digest,
which was one of the most important in
the world at the time,
carried out a macro survey was one of
the largest and most expensive surveys
of all time.
The sample included almost two and a
half million people.
Cool
with Artesia in hand.
The magazine determines that without a
doubt,
Alfred Landon,
the Republican governor of Kansas,
would become the next president of the
United States.
He would defeat the Democrats,
Franklin Roosevelt,
by more than the 14 points.
This is what the survey stated,
but as you all know the truth,
it was quite different.
Roosevelt's utterly destroyed his rival,
beating him by more than 24 points,
and of course he became the new tenant
of the White House.
Since that invokes the Saturdays of the
magazine,
literary digest are considered absolute
nonsense.
They're known to be demographic studies
that are full of errors and plenty of
bias.
The reality is that this magazine
surveys should have been used as a
manual on how not to conduct surveys,
but don't think that this was the only
resoundingly mistake,
not at all.
In fact,
history is littered with examples.
The 1948 campaign because it Harry
Truman,
Franklin Roosevelt success,
they against the Republican New York
State Governor Thomas Dewey,
he'd become tremendously popular for his
prosecution of organized crime,
specifically for his wall with the caper
lucky Luciano.
The fact is that Thomas Dewey was the
big favorite to win the elections.
All the polls presented him as the clear
winner and even some newspapers jumped
ahead to calling him president dewey.
The difference between both candidates
seemed so great so that one of the
country's leading a survey experts,
elmo roper said that he wasn't going to
do any more poles or any surveys or
anything like that.
It just wasn't worth speculating on
something so incredibly obvious.
Dewey,
he would absolutely be the president.
Well,
once again,
history is how I dealt rather
differently.
Dreaming won the election.
By more than 2 million votes.
Have a look at this picture.
It shows the United States President
Harry Truman with a copy of the first
edition of the Chicago daily whose
headline reads dewey defeats Truman.
Yup.
The journalist's thought it was such a
safe choice that they prepared the news
before the vote had even taken place.
And at this point we'd like you to
imagine that newspaper editors face,
but just a second because these big
mistakes,
they don't exclusively come from the u s
for example,
there are the British elections of 1992
all polls showed a clear victory for the
Labour party.
Undoubtedly often 13 years in power.
At the time of the conservatives,
it was coming to an end.
But once again,
the reality was quite different.
And the conservative John Major,
he took over 10 Downing Street.
So check out the huge difference here
between theory and reality.
The fact is that we could spend a lot of
time commenting on all the macro
mistakes that surveys have made.
But let's go back to our initial
question.
Having seen all of this,
can we trust polls?
Can we trust polls?
So now we've seen some of the biggest
mistakes that surveys have made in our
history.
However,
the field has evolved a lot.
And the truth is that it's pretty
efficient.
I mean it works.
A study conducted by professors from the
University of Southampton and the
University of Texas analyzed more than
30,000
surveys for 351 general elections in 45
different countries between 1942 and
2017 study.
The authors compared what the survey
said with what actually happens.
Well,
based on the results in is a question.
Do you know what percentage of the more
than 30,000
surveys analyzed had a failure higher
than their margin of error?
20% 30% no,
it was 2% only 2% of all surveys.
And in addition,
the results showed that accuracy has
improved as the years have gone by.
Bye.
But yeah,
I know Donald Trump's victory against
what the polls prophesized was for many
irrefutable proof that polls,
hi,
useless.
For example,
the Princeton consortium gave Hillary
Clinton and a 99% chance of winning the
New York Times where it's a bit more
cautious setting the probability at 85%
maybe all of these things explain why
according to polls,
ironic I know only at 26% of likely us
voters,
that's one in four trust,
most political polls and of course
taking what happened in the last
presidential campaign into accounts.
They seem to have good reason to do so.
Right,
but hold on a moment because did the
surveys rarely fail that badly in 2016
while the answer may differ a bit from
what we first saw?
Okay.
Yeah,
it is true.
The elections were won by the candidate
at the polls.
Determined would be the loser and it's
precisely due to this fact.
There's many experts are studying what
went wrong and many theories have been
put forward.
For example,
what if trump's voters tend to have to
answer fewer surveys?
What if the response rate is very low
ends?
In the end,
those who answer are accounted for.
What if the probability of correlated
errors wasn't played out well,
et Cetera,
ans yes,
some of these matters will pollute the
results,
but to hold on a second,
if we take a look at the results that
the surveys had estimated that actually
weren't that many mistakes,
you see,
the polls predicted that Hillary would
win the popular vote by about three
points and in fact,
Hillary won the popular vote by more
than two points,
but as you will know,
the candidate with the most rights
doesn't always win elections in the u s
the one who gets the most state
delegates does.
It was right at this point when
determining which state each candidate
would win in the error in forecasting
the winner was caused anyway.
As you can see,
the mistake,
it wasn't that huge and that's taking
into account that electoral polls are
particularly difficult,
perhaps the most difficult,
not only because we need to determine
the favorite candidates,
but also how many of the people
interviewed will eventually vote and how
they'll vote on that precise day.
The truth folks is that surveys are very
accurate when it comes to determining
what the general perception of a
particular issue or subject is and fast
why they're so important for both
politicians and for companies,
they may include a few mistakes.
In fact,
survey results come with a margin of
error include included,
but as we've seen,
the evidence tells us that the real
result in the vast majority of cases is
usually within that margin of error.
And also that's not,
forget how important trends are.
For example,
it's like a thermometer and ground via
Madrid,
which says 600 degrees Fahrenheit.
It's wrong,
but if you walk by tomorrow and it says
650 degrees Fahrenheit,
you know one thing,
it's hotter than yesterday,
Pablo Seaman Politiken but now it's your
turn.
Do you trust the polls?
Well,
leave y'all answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that we're our mind.
Paul says,
this channel is made possible because of
patron and our patrons on that platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political
coverage.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next one.